welcome back women and girls in
afghanistan fearing for their lives and
safety as the taliban takes control
there are reports that the taliban is
already forcing young girls to marry
their fighters while those concerns are
growing president biden says he supports
defending human rights
we'll continue to speak out for the
basic rights of the afghan people of
women and girls
just as we speak out all over the world
i've been clear
the human rights must be the center of
our foreign policy
not the periphery
but the way to do it is not through
endless military deployments
that's fine but what happens to the
women and girls now who are fearing for
their lives
very bad things yeah and in record time
the problem with
putting a statement out there or having
people talk around the issue and you
brought this up in the last segment we
have social media we've all seen the
pictures now and there's not multiple
ways to interpret them it's absolute
horror on the streets it's hard in the
airport our embassy's been cleared our
flag was coming home and
that has real symbolic and practical
meaning we are not there anymore to
protect them and i i think there's this
really interesting dichotomy going on
and we've talked about the intelligence
community but congress also got it right
on this so just a little while ago jason
crowe who's a congressman and a veteran
had a bill
putting forward to fast-track visa
applications for afghans in light of the
fact that we have decided that we're
going to be coming home
it was hugely popular only 16 uh
congress people voted against it those
are the kinds of actions that people who
have who are serving that we have sent
there
no need to be taken and we need answers
in an accountability chain of of how
this ended up in this way because those
are the people who are going to be
suffering the most from a hasty
withdrawal
but brian is it just lip service you
know it's like we heard the same thing
from vice president harris when she
visited the border and she talked about
you know an initiative that she had
helping women and girls in guam but
still really not a root cause so you can
talk about it you can send thoughts and
prayers but what does that really do we
don't even in her case let me just read
you what she said about the women
she said nothing there's nothing to read
she has totally skipped over the fact
that women will now go back into the
back of the house be told to raise the
kids you're not allowed to go to school
and when they say they can go to school
well how many years and what will they
do and i'll bring back to this comment
that's widely circulated but just in
case you missed it richard holbrooke in
his diary said this about joe biden when
he came to visit he's trying to say you
got to put more time and effort what
about the women you can't want to pull
out of afghanistan in 2008 biden said
replied with a history lesson
he said
what he said about the american
obligation afghan like the girl in the
kabul school biden replied the history
lesson from the u.s withdrawal from
southeast asia f them we don't have to
worry about that we did in vietnam nixon
and kissinger got a pass ah that's how
he felt in his prime how do you think he
feels now i don't know but he's he's
saying that you know fighting misogyny
and fighting for women that is uh the
the hallmark of his presidency should he
get a pass well i think that um
nancy pelosi is going to give him a pass
so she's speaker of the house and she
said uh yesterday yesterday before the
president said anything that the
president is to be commended for the
clarity of purpose of his statement on
afghanistan this is the two-page-long
statement he uh issued uh and it says we
are concerned about reports regarding
the taliban's brutal treatment of all
afghans especially women and girls but i
also think in some ways they threw up
their hands now john kirby the spokesman
the pentagon i actually think that the
way that he answered the afghan reporter
was with a lot more empathy and care
and concern and
really more representative of how
americans feel which is we know this is
going to be bad for you and we are sorry
and it was i thought that was a lot more
heartfelt and for the tone and tenor of
the president's speech maybe could have
used a little bit more of that yeah
because you know this is real life and
real death greg and and i i think she's
absolutely right i don't think the
president touched on that enough and
sometimes uh these platitudes are empty
because who is going to document the the
lives and murders of the women who are
left behind and essentially subjugated
yeah i mean and how how can we be
exporting our values right when we
consider in our own country that that
our values are oppressive you know will
the squad terrible people yeah we're
terrible people will the squad defend or
condemn this cultural resurgence right
we've we've read it we've read hard
lefties defend the role of women in
radical islam so it's going to be really
hard to see these people say wow we need
more american values over there right
good luck well in terms of the squad
they need uh more history lessons
because rasheed sleep uh sort of botched
her explanation of soviet involvement in
afghanistan hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else